Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Diastabende Arstin auf der Station und würde gerne das Erstgespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, das ist Ordnung, Frau Dr.
Okay. So als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Rainer Müller.
Rainer Müller. Frau Müller, könnten Sie Ihre…
Herr Müller, können Sie Ihre Namen für Ihren Nachnamen beschreiben?
Ja. R-E-N-E-R. Rainer.
R-E-N-E-R.
Ja, ja. Meine Nachname ist M-U-L-L-E-R Müller.
Okay. Herr Müller, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
45 Jahre alt. Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
12. Juni 1970.
70?
Ja.
Juni. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind? Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 72 und 75 Kilogramm.
75. Okay. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schmidt.
Herr Schmidt.
D oder T?
D-T. Ender.
Ender T. Okay.
D-T. Ender D-T Schmidt.
D-T. Okay. Herr Schmidt.
Herr Müller, was für Sie heute so ist?
Wie kann ich Ihnen erinnern?
Ich habe eine starke Bauchschmerzen.
Starke Bauchschmerzen. Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind besonders in meiner Nabel.
Aber ich bin sehr schmerzhaft.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Zwei Wochen? Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Dass diese Schmerzen krampfartig und stehend, brennend?
Ja, diese Schmerzen sind kolikartig und drückend.
Aber besonders kolikartig.
Okay.
Schmerzen sind nicht irgendwo hinaus?
Schmerzen sind nicht irgendwo. Schmerzen sind nicht irgendwo hinaus.
Okay.
Haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe jetzt Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von eins bis zehn?
Wobei ein sehr lahtes Sein sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Das sind ungefähr fünf bis sieben.
Fünf bis sieben? Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen zumindest das Gespräch aushalten oder brauchen Sie sofort einen Schmerzentner?
Ja, ich kann warten, Doktor.
Okay.
Denken Sie, es gibt eine bestimmte Auslöse für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, eigentlich muss ich sagen, vor zwei Wochen bin ich mit meiner Cousine in ein Restaurant gegangen.
Wir haben mit ihnen eine Pizza gegessen.
Ich denke, nach dem Essen hatte ich diese Schmerzen, Doktor.
Nach dem Essen, okay.
Trinken Sie auch Alkohol? Haben Sie vor zwei Wochen Alkohol getrunken?
Ja, ich trinke normalerweise ein Glas Wein bis oder fünf oder sechs Mal pro Woche.
Okay.
Aber ich trinke jede Woche Alkohol, Doktor.
Okay. Aber haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, nein. Das ist einmalig.
Okay. Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden beim Hausarzt?
Ja, Doktor. Vor zwei Tagen war ich bei meinem Hausarzt.
Sie hat mir eine Medikamente angenommen.
Ich muss erinnern, es heißt Imodium.
Imodium, okay.
Ja, ich habe zweimal angenommen, aber das war mir nicht geholfen.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber auch, Frau Hermüller?
Fieber? Ich habe keine Fieber, nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Sterfrost?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich habe ungefähr zwei Kilogramm abgenommen.
Seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen?
Ja, zwei Kilogramm.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, ja. Ich habe Übelkeit.
Okay. Haben Sie Erbrochen auch?
Ja, ja. Erbrochen, ja.
Wie oft haben Sie Erbrochen?
Meine Erbrochenung ist plötzlich aufgetreten.
Aber in der Verlustszeit ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich in zwei Häusern einmal Erbrochen.
Okay. Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Gelbe.
Gelbe? Ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Haben Sie Durchfall?
Ja, ja. Seit zwei Tagen hatte ich auch Durchfall.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Ja, vielleicht vier und fünf Mal täglich.
Vier und fünf Mal, okay.
Ja. Ich hatte Wasserigen.
Ja, Wasserigen. Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Ja, nein. Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Hat der Stuhl ein unangenehmes Geruch?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Apathit?
Normalerweise gut, aber deswegen diese Beschwerden habe ich keinen guten Apathit.
Ich habe kaum Apathit.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja. Vor etwa ein paar Tagen, ungefähr seit einer Woche, schlafe ich nicht gut.
Weil ich viele Mal auf die Toilette gehen muss.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Gibt es andere Personen, die in der Umgebung in den Hebe-Schwerden gehabt haben?
Ich wohne alleine, aber ich habe keine Ahnung. Nein.
Okay. Ihr Freundin, seine Freundin, hat in der Umgebung in den Hebe-Schwerden geschlafen.
Eine Cousine, oder?
Ja, Cousine.
Ich habe gehört, dass sie sich an die Änderung der Doktorzikrone befestigt hat.
Okay.
Herr Müller, ist bei Ihnen irgendetwas mit der Chronischen Erkrankung bekannt?
Chronischen Erkrankung?
Ja, ich habe vor einem Monat
meine Hausart gewesen.
Sie hat mir gesagt, ich habe die Tätige Vergrößerung
für die Stärken durchgeführt.
Wie bitte? Für?
Für die Stärken durchgeführt.
Okay. Nehmen Sie Medikamente dagegen für diese Beschwerden?
Nein, sie hat mir gesagt, sie muss gehandelt werden.
Aber eine Termin, nehmen Sie eine Termin, ich warte.
Okay. Noch etwas? Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Ich habe seit fünf Jahren Bluthochdruck.
Okay. Noch etwas?
Ich habe manchmal Tatschikarde oder Herzklopfen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber ich denke, ich habe Herzrhythmstörungen.
Da haben Sie gesagt, Sie haben zwei Jahre.
Aber eine Erkrankung bei Ihnen, eine Erkrankung, ist nicht bekannt?
Ja, ja, nicht bekannt.
Okay. Jetzt haben Sie Herzklopfen, Herzrazen?
Ja, ich habe Gesagtoktor, ich bin manchmal mit Herzklopfen oder Herzrazen.
Haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Nein, nein, ich habe keine Hüsten oder Atemnot.
Okay. Haben Sie Brüste Schmerzen oder ein Eingefühl?
Nein, nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Und noch etwas?
Vor ein paar Jahren hatte ich eine Herzblutentzündung mit Antimiotik behandelt.
Okay. Vor sechs Monaten. Okay.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, da gegen meine Hochblutdruck, nehme ich etabliche zwei Malteglische.
Kennen Sie die Namen, diese Medikamente, diese Medikamente?
Ja, vielleicht. Ja, ja, ja, ich kenne es. Ramupril.
Ramupril. Welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
5 Milligramm täglich, zwei Mal.
Zwei Mal, okay. Und?
Morgen und Abend.
Okay. Und noch andere Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Okay. Sie nehmen regelmäßig Ramupril ein?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja. Mit 30 Jahren hatte ich einen Unfall und meine Unterarm gebrockt. Und ich hatte eine Operation.
Okay. Rachen Sie, Herr Miller?
Ja, leider. Ja, ja, leider. Ich rauche 10 Zigaretten täglich.
Seit wann haben Sie geraucht?
Seit 20 Jahren.
20 Jahre. Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich trinke ein Glas Wein 5 oder 6 Mal pro Woche.
5 oder 6 Mal, okay. Ein Glas Wein.
Das ist eine rhythmische Frage. Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe nicht probiert.
Okay. Sehr gut. Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich treibe manchmal laufen, manchmal Tennis spielen, ja.
Wie oft in einer Woche?
Zwei Mal pro Woche.
Okay. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen? Bei Vater oder bei Mutter?
Mein Vater ist mit 67 Jahren an Darmkrebs gestorben.
67?
Meine Mutter ist mit Lungenkrebs gestorben. Und auch er hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Meine Mutter mit 60 Jahren...
Entschuldigung, hat Ihr Vater einen Myokartinfarkt? Hatte er einen Myokartinfarkt?
Hatte einen Myokartinfarkt, aber sie hat...
Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Ja, sie ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter mit 60 Jahren an Darmkrebs gestorben.
Darmkrebs?
Ja.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid.
Danke schön.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind, okay. Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Lehrer. Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie leben allein?
Ja, ich bin Geschwister und wohne allein.
Geschwister, okay. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder. Eine Tochter und ein Sohn. Sie sind ein Kind.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Haben Sie... haben Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Allergisch? Ja, ich habe gegen Penis-Allergie.
Wie reagiert Sie darauf?
Das ausreicht sich Atemnot und Yukreis.
Okay. Waren Sie in Lestezheit im Ausland?
Nein, Doktor. Was bedeutet Lestezheit?
In den sechs Monaten.
In den sechs Monaten bin ich im Deutschland.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Müller, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Frau Doktor, was habe ich?
Ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen, Durchfall und ich habe gesagt, meine Mutter ist an Darmkrebs gestorben.
Ja.
Ich habe Krebs?
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, Herr Müller.
Aber momentan gibt es keine Grundsorge.
Krebs ist nicht immer 100% erblich.
Sie können viele Ursachen haben.
Um eine neue Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, wir werden alle nötigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde die Körperliere untersuchen, danach Blut abnehmen und einige Laborwerte überprüfen.
Ich werde Ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald ich Ihnen die Ergebnisse vorgelegt habe, kann ich Ihnen eine genaue Sache sagen.
Bitte gehen Sie in den Behandlungszimmer und ich werde gleich zu Ihnen kommen.
Ok, danke schön, ich warte auf Sie.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Der Patient heißt Rainer Müller, ist 45 Jahre alt, 1,72 Meter groß und wiegt 75 Kilogramm.
Herr Müller stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Wochen Bechderhänder, Zunehmender, Kolikartikard, Diffuser,
Abdominalschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Die Schmerzen sind nach Versehen einer Pizza plötzlich aufgetreten und hätten sich mit der Zeit verschlimmert.
Der Patient hat vor zwei Tagen beim Hausarzt aufgesucht und hat ihm Imodium verschiebt, aber ohne Besserung.
Der Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 bis 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Der Patient klagte über seit zwei Wochen Neusea und besonders seit zwei Tagen Erbrochenes.
Erbrochenes sah gärblich aus.
Der Patient klagte über seit zwei Tagen Diarrhoch, Vastereckdiarrhoch, 4 bis 5 Mal täglich.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Anastasie, Schütterfrust oder Basalasenstörungen wurden verneint.
In der vegetativen Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inapathens und Insomni. Schmerzbedingte Inapathens und Insomni.
Der Patient leidet vor Erkrankungen vor ein Monaten an Prostata-Hyperpilosi und seit fünf Jahren an arteriöle Hipertonie.
Er hat seit zwei Jahren unbekannte Herzstörungen wie Tachycardia und Herzkloof.
Der Patient leidet vor zwei Monaten aufgrund einer Cystitis mit Antibiosie behandelt.
Er ist seit 30 Jahren aufgrund einer Unterarmfraktur eine Osteosynthese durchgeführt worden.
Er nimmt regelmäßig RamiPril 5 mg zweimal täglich.
Er rauft seit 15 Jahren Zigaretten täglich und trinkt ein Glas Wein 5 bis 6 pro Woche.
Er trinkt regelmäßig Sport, läuft oder spielt Tennis zweimal pro Woche.
Er arbeitet als Lehrer, ist geschieden und lebt allein. Er hat zwei gesunde Kinder, ist vollständig geübt und hat Pelis-Allergie mit Symptomen wie Dyspne und Pyrurhitus.
Der Anamnese ist unaufällig.
In der Familie Anamnese wurde angegeben, dass sein Vater mit 62 Jahren an Bronchial-Carsen verstorben ist.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Der Anamnist ist in der Familie Anamnese und hat eine Gastroenteritis.
Als differential Diagnosen kommen Magen Ulcus Deodone, Ulcus Pepticus, Ulcus Ventricular, Ulcus Deodone und Magenkrebs.
Das ist der Anamnist.
Sie sagen einfach Gastritis, Reissdarm-Syndrom.
In diesem Fall denken wir erst an die Magenkrebs, Ulcus Deodone und Magenkrebs.
Als differential Diagnosen kommen Gastritis, Ulcus Ventricular und Reissdarm-Syndrom in Betra.
Oder Ernerungvergiftung.
Und Sie sind verletzt?
Ja.
Die Anamnise wurde durchgeführt.
Ich werde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde darauf achten, ob es Lassschmerzen, Durchschmerzen und Abwehrspannung vorhanden sind.
Ich beurteile den Allgemeinen Zustand der Patienten.
Hören Sie Darmgeräusche ab?
Ja.
Ich auskultiere Darmgeräusche und erwarte ...
Vermerte Darmgeräusche?
Ja, vermehrte Darmgeräusche.
Ich beurteile den Allgemeinen Zustand der Patienten über die Hydratation.
Dann werde ich die Labouren untersuchen.
Ich werde die Anamnise durchführen.
Okay.
Ich werde eine Abdomenssonographie durchführen.
Ich werde die Patologien auslesen.
Und wenn es so ist, kann ich eine Kolonoscopy verlassen.
Jetzt? Würden Sie jetzt eine Kolonoscopy verlassen?
Nein, nicht jetzt.
Wenn es nicht unklar ist, können wir eine Kolonoscopy verlassen.
Koloskopie?
Koloskopie.
Ich werde die Anamnise durchführen.
Wenn ich die Diagnose bestätige, schlage ich die vorgelegte Therapie vor.
Dann würde ich die Allgemeinen Zustand besser stabilisieren.
Ich würde einen Venösenzugang legen und eine Schmerzmittelverbreitung ausreichen.
Dann würde ich, wenn ich eine bakterielle Gastroenteritis bestätige,
Antibiotentherapie beginnen.
Ich empfehle den Patienten mehr Flüssigkeit.
Ausreichende Wasser trinken.
Leichte Essen nehmen.
Nein.
Okay.
Ich denke, der Patient sollte eine Woche in Ruhe bleiben.
Dann würde ich eine Krankheit schreiben.
Das ist alles.
Was ist Ihre letzte Sätze?
Falls Sie eine Diagnose haben, würde ich meinen Patienten untersuchen.
Sind Sie mit dieser Vorgangsweise einverstanden?
Ja, das ist sehr schwer gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Diagnose ein Ulkosventröküli ist.
Wie können Sie Ulkosventröküli ausschließen?
Die beste Wahl ist die Usefago-Gastro-Dodonskopie.
Die Usefago-Gastro-Dodonskopie zeigt uns die möglichen Pathologien.
Wir können eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Wir können diese Probe untersuchen.
Deswegen können wir Ulkosventröküli ausschließen.
Wie können Sie Erneuerung und Vergiftung ausschließen?
Die Stuhlprobe zeigt uns die möglichen Pathologien.
Wir können eine Bakterie oder Viren bestätigen.
Auch die Anamnese zeigt uns die Ernährung, die Giftung der Patienten und auch ihre Kusen haben
Wir haben eine Ernährung, die Giftung, aber ich sollte eine Stuhlprobe untersuchen.
Welche Fragen sind sehr wichtig, um eine Ernährung, Vergiftung, Auschüchselnis zu machen?
Gibt es um eine Gastroenteritis Ausschüchseln, auch um Ernährung, Vergiftung?
Wir können die Reissdarm-Syndrom Ausschüchseln.
Reissdarm-Syndrom?
Ja.
Wir können eine Atomhandsynographie dafür nehmen, aber die Kolonskopie ist der beste Wahl für die ...
Was erwarten Sie von der Kolonskopie in dieser Form?
Für den Reissdarm-Syndrom?
Ja.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich erwarte keine bestimmten Befunde.
Aber mit der Kolonskopie können wir andere mögliche Pathologien ausschließen.
Dann können wir diese Erkrankung im Reissdarm-Syndrom sagen.
Welche anderen Pathologien ausschließen bei der Kolonskopie?
Ja, zuerst kann ich die Tumor-Ausschleißung und die Serativkollide und chronische Erkrankungen ausschließen.
Mit der Kolonskopie.
Dann ...
Ja.
Divertikulose?
Ja, Divertikulose auch.
Aber ...
Können Sie bei der Kolonskopie eine Divertikulitis ausschließen?
Ja, wir können ...
In akuten Fallen ...
In akuten Attacken ...
Bei der Divertikulose ...
können wir nicht eine Kolonskopie durchführen.
Wie können Sie eine Divertikulose diögnosieren?
Die Xanographie ...
ist die, äh ...
zuerst wir müssen ...
Was erwarten Sie bei der Ultraschall der Abdomens um eine Divertikulitis?
Die Diagnostisieren?
Ich erwarte nicht eine bestimmte Defund mit Xanographie für ...
Nein, nein, gibt es bestimmte ...
Zeichen?
Die Divertikulose ist eine ...
Ja.
Ich erwarte nicht ...
Äh ...
Das ist ein gewisser Zeichen.
Das ist ein Gasgenau.
Aber ein Zylinder-Bildungszeichen.
Das ist ein Wunder.
Das muss ein Wunder sein.
Ja.
Weil das Köln-Bildungszeichen wie ein Zylinder-Bildungszeichen ...
verkleidet ist.
Das ist ein typischer Wunder bei Ultraschall.
Ultraschall.
Für eine Divertikulose.
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.